[Musique]
bonsoir conflit naissant enfermé ces
nouvelles oxymore du moment comment
obliger les français à rester chez eux
tout en leur permettant d'aller dehors
depuis ce week-end ses dilemmes devant
lequel ces mille gouvernement mais la
sortie de crise passera bel et bien par
la vaccination insiste tant de la part
du même gouvernement d'ailleurs le mois
prochain
35 centres de vaccination géants vont
être mises en place en france avec
l'aide de l'armée
ça tombe bien alors après le nous sommes
j'en garde emmanuel macron dans ce
contexte les élections départementales
et régionales qui sont prévues en juin
prochain pourront-elles avoir lieu on va
aborder toutes ces questions et bien
d'autres avec notre invité d'aujourd'hui
patrick mignola bonsoir président du
modem président du groupe modem à
l'assemblée nationale merci d'être dans
l'audition publique
le rendez vous du lundi soir sur lcp
public sénat avec le figaro nous sommes
ensemble pendant une heure et on va
d'abord parler du carnaval de marseille
le vrai faux carnaval parce que c'était
un carnaval non autorisée il ya eu plus
de 6000 personnes qui sont descendues
dans les rues de façon spontanée a
priori l'image a choqué pas mal de gens
gérald darmanin le miz l'intérieur dit
il va falloir des taxes des sanctions
est-ce qu'à vos yeux ce n'est pas
finalement l'illustration du ras-le-bol
d'un entre contraintes sanitaires de
véraison ouf on en a tous assez on
voudrait que ce soit terminé
mais une immense majorité de français
c'est une surprise pour moi de tous les
jours applique les règles font attention
prennent soin d'eux mêmes prennent soin
des autres et pour moi qu'ils pensent
souvent que il n'y a pas suffisamment de
contrôles
au fond on est un peu choqué finalement
de devoir assez peu alors que dans le
premier confinement voyez souvent des
gendarmes les policiers auraient plus de
contrat dans la rue moi je crois qu'il
faut plus contrôler parce que quand tout
le monde joue le jeu il faut que les
contrevenants soient sanctionnés donc
gérald darmanin raisons effectivement il
faut qu' il ya des comparutions
immédiates que des sanctions tombent
parce que c'est vrai que c'est pas
forcément facile cette nouvelle forme de
confinement mais là ils font exprès de
pas comprendre que de confiner sans
enfermer ça ne veut pas dire sortir
dehors et faire n'importe quoi vit sur
le canal de marseille s'en va y revenir
sur cette formule sur le carnaval de
marseille vous vous dites il faut des
sanctions mais en même temps un peu
partout en france renforcé les contrôles
oui bien sûr d'accord sûr mais on n'en
sortira que si on est solidaires
ensemble et les misères les contrôler
j'ai compris sont solidaires à 90 ou 95
% on peut pas c'est un peu comme le code
de la route avec les chauffards on peut
pas laisser 5 ou 10% des personnes faire
n'importe quoi et là de toute évidence
les images étaient très chaud contre ce
week-end c'est quand même et c'est le
grand cafouillage autour de la nouvelle
attestation de sortie dans les 16
départements qui sont confinés même si
on n'utilise plus beau aujourd'hui il
eut trois versions en 48 heures c'est
plus qu'un couac là alors en tant que
membre de la majorité est ce que vous
êtes prêt vous à couvrir c'est quoi qui
allait justifier
vous savez moi je pense que
l'attestation c'est une bonne idée parce
que en fait ça nous permet tous un peu
comme le masque de faire attention c'est
quand on sort si on doit faire une
attestation si on doit mettre un masque
pas forcément on va limiter nos
interactions et on va prendre soin des
autres
après ça je crois que notre pays va
finir par crever si on fait pas quelque
chose d'un principe de précaution qui
est mal compris aujourd'hui principe de
précaution c'est fait pour protéger les
français
c'est ce que doit faire le tout
responsable public quand il est aux
responsabilités doit protéger les
français
hélas avec mes principes de précaution
ce n'est pas le principe de
déresponsabilisation
on protège les autres on se protège pas
soi même et aux faut arrêter les
attestations l'administration non il
faut qu'on arrête de faire du peuple a
pour du pape la scène car c'est à dire
que quand on peut faire tenir sur une
page le motif de son déplacement
pourquoi en faire deux quand on peut
faire un protocole de dix pages pourquoi
faire 48 pages ou 60 jours trois hauts
responsables de ce couac parce qu'on dit
c'est l'administration mais qui donne
des ordres d'administration et basse
d'abord seule politique voilà donc le
politique est responsable
nous sommes responsables qui s'est
aujourd'hui c'est le premier ministre à
l'intérieur c'est dans chaque ministère
le ministre doit commander à son
administration à l'assemblée nationale
les députés doivent décider de faire la
loi mais de veiller à son application
les maires quand ils prennent une
disposition doivent y est ce que le
doigt elle c'est gentil ça allait bien
alors là je roulais dernier quand on a
voulu réouvrir les écoles on n'arrivait
plus à trouver les atsem les personnels
non enseignants parce que les mères
savaient pas où ils étaient si je
comprends bien là ses premiers disques
quoique moi je ce que je crois
fondamentalement c'est que notre
responsabilité c'est que depuis le début
de ce quinquennat on n'a pas fait mieux
quelqu'un cana précédent on n'a pas fait
mieux que les législatures précédentes
c'est à dire que on n'a pas su réformer
l'administration de l'intérieur et donc
on a des fonctionnaires moi je les
défends toujours parce que c'est facile
de se moquer des fonctionnaires mais ils
sont compétents qui sont engagés mais
quand c'est une procédure est prouvé il
s'affaire quand c'est quelque chose de
nouveau et là c'était le cas il fallait
produire une attestation pour quelque
chose de nouveau
voilà le principe de précaution c'est
d'abord se protéger soi même ouvrir le
parapluie
plutôt protéger les autres et donc c'est
faire deux pages quand on pourra en
faire qu'une
et c'est au fond en rajouter en rajouter
toujours plus c'est incroyable que ce
pays est le génie de prendre des bonnes
décisions mais d'être capable de les
appliquer en moins de trois semaines
mais c'est la faute des politiques avez
vous dit mais on va maintenant
poursuivre le débat avec brigitte
boucher de lcp bonsoir brigitte - safran
ci s'est entretenu de public sénat
bonsoir table francis tg tri commence on
va continuer sur évidemment la
vaccination
oui vous en parliez à l'instant olivier
ferrand annonce la mise en place de 35
vaccinodromes or il y a deux mois et ne
voulait pas en entendre parler est ce
que c'est un échec de la stratégie du
gouvernement un aveu d'échec finalement
bâton contre là c'est l'inversé c'est
parce que maintenant qu'on reçoit plus
de 12 effectivement ça vaut le coup
d'ouvrir deux grands centres de
vaccination stratégie tout à fait de
passer par les pharmaciens de passer par
les médecins traitants ou de passer par
les vaccinodromes et bien que la seule
solution pour sortir de cette situation
c'est effectivement de vacciner
massivement et qu'on arrive tous à une
immunité général au début on n'avait pas
beaucoup de doses et donc on s'est
retrouvé avec certaines collectivités
certaines mairies ou certainement il
avait voulu faire un petit peu de
publicité moss et je défends toujours
les maires je l'étais 20 ans mais je
défends plutôt les petits que les grands
mères les grands mères ils ont tendance
à faire un petit mot love et donc ils
faisaient les malins ouvrir dix centres
de vaccination pour vous ouvrez 10
centres de vaccination alors que vous
recevez 500 doses par semaine à 50,12
par centres de vaccination vous voyez
bien que c'est pas la peine d'ouvrir des
vaccins
dix vaccins peuvent axa prennent du
retard et on attend toujours les
astrazeneca prévu pour cette semaine
gilles boucher ou sait parfaitement lire
et vous connaissez parfaitement les
chiffres on a eu 10 millions de doses
on aura 13 millions de doses le mois
prochain donc désormais il faut monter
en puissance c'est à dire qu'on a juste
remis les choses à l'endroit
plutôt qu ouvrir des centres de
vaccination pour faire des vaccins par
jour désormais au vert dès vaccinodromes
pour en faire des milliers c'est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle
thierry breton le commissaire européen
au marché intérieur dit qu'on n'a pas
besoin du vaccin russe spoutnik
est ce que vous y voyez vous un choix
sanitaires là dedans ou un choix
politique dans les discussions que
parfois on n'avait que olivier ferrand
dont je me demande s'il arrive parfois à
dormir ce qui travaillent jour et nuit
ce garçon pour réussir cette campagne de
vaccination on finissait par se faire la
réflexion à force de commander des
vaccins européen pour la plupart il
faudrait pas qu'on se retrouve à un
moment avec trop de doses on en est loin
on en est loin mais aujourd'hui on a
commandé 200 millions de vaccins pour 66
millions de français a besoin du
spoutnik il peut y avoir de perte de la
perte en ligne
mais il faut qu'on fasse attention il
faut pas que nous saignons à
l'affolement
on est capable aujourd'hui de monter en
puissance et avec 10 millions demain 15
millions de vaccins et d'agressions
chaleur ajouté de rajouter 100 me
reposer la question mais l'idée c'était
ce vaccin spoutnik est-ce que vous
envoyez un choix un choix sanitaires ou
un choix politique
au menu enfin je vois pas de deux de ses
grilles via sionisme anti slave
sur ce sujet je pense qu'on a quand même
cette chance malgré tout tant mieux
faisons un peu de de cocorico européen
on a eu la chance en moins d'un an de
trouver un vaccin ça n'était jamais
arrivé dans l'histoire de l'humanité
ce sont les européens qui les ont
inventés pour la plupart des français
parfois qui dirigent ces sociétés
dommage qu'ils aient pas une société
française qui ait pu le faire mais si on
peut faire travailler les européens pour
guérir les européens mais oui effectuée
dit trop de doses mais en fait on en a
acheté à l'échelle européenne et on les
a distribuées en fonction de la
population auront voilà que l'allemagne
et l'italie se disent prêtes à commander
du vaccin sportif donc je considère par
exemple qui n'ont pas suffisamment de
doses et son prêt du coup à prendre
leurs distances avec laurent berthet
kazim est chômé mais chacun chacun peut
faire ses choix ou c'est en fait
l'important c'était de pouvoir faire des
vaccinations avec une commande réalisée
à l'échelle de l'union européenne à
l'échelle de l'union européenne on sait
qu'on a commandée de quoi faire de 12
par européens vivent sur le continent
ça c'est réussi maintenant c'est mis en
place alors je vois bien que la pression
est très forte et quand vous êtes sur
moi je voudrais être vaccinés
immédiatement donc vous avez tendance à
à commander et assure commandé en
regardant les choses en face à un moment
on sait combien nous sommes on sait
qu'il ya besoin de 200 millions de doses
si pour faire plaisir on commande sont
mis en plus c'est que j'ai vu ça moi
dans un certain nombre de campagnes de
tests la région auvergne rhône-alpes à
un moment elle organise une grande
campagne de tests avant noël c'était
plutôt une bonne idée
ils ont commandé tellement de masques de
gants de sur mulhouse et charlotte que
maintenant on en est à louer des
entrepôts pour pouvoir les stocker oui
mais ça ça revient a toujours refusé non
parce qu'en plus il ya un délai dans le
oui deux ans il faut les détruire
soyaux faisons attention il faut qu'on
puisse vacciner tout le monde qu'on
commande le maximum mais faut pas qu'on
fasse n'importe quoi tout ça c'est de
l'argent pourtant l'allemagne qui est
très souvent cité comme exemple vous
pour vous il faut pas que la france
suive cet exemple il faut pas qu'elles
commandent indépendamment de l'union
européenne des nouveaux stocks de
vaccins si aujourd'hui ce qui nous
fournissent les vaccins n'étaient pas en
capacité de le faire aux et vu les
polémiques autour d'astrazeneca
mais si nous voulons tous cédé à
l'affolement et que demain on se met à
commander un milliard de doses pour une
population cinq de 50 millions
d'habitants je suis sûr vous me poserez
la question si dans six mois en
anticipation c'est l'affolement pour
quand on voit ça
il m'a demandé si vous commandez dix
fois plus que vos besoins cetc c'est
plus que de l'affolement c'est du
gaspillage d'argent public alors les il
ya aussi la question des désaccords qui
se posent les cas dans les écoles
augmentent est ce qu'il est raisonnable
pour vous de les garder ouvertes dans
les 16 départements confiné 20 où il ya
les mesures de freinage aujourd'hui on a
eu très peu de cas de diffusion et de
kloster dans les écoles d'abord parce
que la procédure qui a eu du mal et de
mise en oeuvre
ça a pris trois ou quatre semaines
désormais fonctionne bien c'est à dire
que dès qu'un cas il ya un isolement je
le vois dans l'école de mon petit
dernier
ça fonctionne très bien la classe ferme
elle ré ouvre là vraiment le la
procédure de précaution est très bien
appliqué
et oui bien sûr il faut laisser les
écoles ouvertes mais pour nous les
primes sont pas ce choix mais tous les
pays font pas ce choix nous avons fait
ce choix nous pouvons être fiers de ce
choix parce que qui souffrent d'écoles
fermées les plus fragiles les enfants ce
qu'ils entendent ceux qui n'ont pas les
moyens mais je parle bien des anges il
sait ce dont le papa et la maman ont pas
forcément fait d'études ont pas
forcément la disponibilité peuvent pas
s'occuper d'eux à la maison pour les
faire progresser et en fait vous vous
élargissez encore plus les failles à
sociale et donc il faut lui qui est
absolument contre ça ainsi on doit
laisser une seule chose ouvert ce sont
les écoles est-ce que vous pensez que
dans ce contexte les enseignants doivent
être vaccinés en priorité
oui je le crois je joue d'ailleurs
twitté je crois le le la semaine
dernière je crois que je crois que les
les enseignants ne doivent absolument
pas payer même partiellement les tests
qu'on laisserait salivaire comptes en
euros qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire ça c'est encore une histoire
pour faire de 3 sous de d'économie ont
fait pas d'économies sur les hussards
noirs de la république auquel on ferait
payer leur uniforme ça marche pas ça une
question que le gouvernement prenne les
mesures pour soutenir seigneur et la
charge est évidemment une discussion
aujourd'hui olivier derand est en train
de travailler dessus mathieu est en
train de travailler dessus je comprends
bien en fait la question ça reste à
charge c'est la question très simple
c'est la question du ticket modérateur
en fait qui s'applique à tout le monde
donc en fait ça a été décidée contre les
enseignants mais je pense que
symboliquement on doit dire que les
enseignants ne doivent pas payer leurs
masques ne doivent pas avoir de ticket
mourad de modérateur sur les tests et
devront demain et prioritaires à la
vaccination d'accord c'est ça que je
voulais vous faire redire brigitte oui
vous êtes reçus demain à matignon avec
les autres présidents de groupe de la
majorité qu est ce qui se prépare bon
travail sur la convention citoyenne jeu
comme on le fait le climat comme enjeu
sur le climat mais pardon le pose sur le
la grande loi sur le l'écologie on a
quelques sujets de fond sur lesquels il
faut qu'on échange parce que on a fait
un pari extrêmement risqué c'est la
première fois depuis le grenelle de jean
louis borloo que nous nous allons faire
un tel pas en matière écologique
or on veut pas avoir une démarche quasi
théologique sur le sujet on veut pas
prononcer des interdictions sans
solution on veut pouvoir faire muter
l'économie française vers plus de
verdissement en particulier en faisant
appel à des énergies décarbonées
pourquoi ça coince et on voit ce à quoi
est ce qui coince et d'un hommage
aujourd'hui
les menus végétariens à la cantine ya
deux ou trois ans il ya une polémique
qui est en train de s'annoncer sur les
menus végétariens je suis assez étonné
aussi quand j'étais maire en 2015
j'ai mis en place dans toutes nos
cantines et pourtant on était une petite
commune 8000 habitants quatre écoles on
a émis des petits self où il y avait
trois entrées trois plats trois desserts
et à chaque fois les combinaisons
d'ailleurs apporte elle avait le même
apport protéique calorique
ça permettait aux enfants de choisir ça
ne veut rien faire c'est ludique et il y
avait toujours une combinaison
végétarienne mais alors si on a vraiment
on a vraiment un espèce de génie
national à chaque fois pour inventer une
polémique sur un sujet qui n'est alors
soit c'est quoi ce lobby des viandes
vous êtes soumis au levier la viande non
c'est parce qu'en fait vous avez une
partie des parlementaires et je respecte
toutes les opinions qui sont légitimes
une partie des parlementaires qui
voudraient imposer qu'il n'y ait un menu
que végétariens et une partie des
parlementaires qui sont opposés à ce
qu'ils aient un menu végétarien
prenons une décision simple on peut
apprendre aux enfants à bien manger en
leur permettant de choisir et faire des
choix
cent mètres du confessionnel quel qu'il
soit ce soit un confessionnelles
écologistes - confessionnels religieux
dans l'assiette de nos enfants c'est pas
sur eux qu'il faut pauline alors on va
revenir parce qu'on pensait en vous
posant la question que ça aurait été au
cours autour d'arbitrage au cours des
crises sanitaires on va revenir à la
crise sanitaire parce qu'il y aura un
débat qui sera organisé mercredi à
l'assemblée nationale sur le suivi de la
crise sanitaire vous qu'est ce que vous
allez demander en tant que modem sur la
crise sur la crise sanitaire
je pense que le travail qui a été fait
par la mission d'information au
parlement a été un bon travail même si
d'aucuns ont essayé de
l'instrumentaliser pour en faire des
polémiques
je crois qu'on s'est pas suffisamment
poser la question de la réactivité
lorsque nous prenions des mesures et je
l'évoqué d'un mot tout à l'heure quand
on parlait de l'attestation je crois que
ça l'est
on n'a pas fait tout bien depuis un an
mais en tout cas on a fait tout ce qu'on
pouvait et souvent on a pris de bonnes
décisions et on a eu de bonnes
intuitions mais souvent le l'application
a pêché alors soit parce que le
politique et d'administration national
soit parce que le politique et
l'administration locale empêché à mettre
les choses qu'est ce que vous allez
demander à l'occasion et donc on va
demander à ce que nous puissions avoir
une mission d'information pour tirer les
conséquences en vue de l'avenir sur la
forme en mode projet d'adaptation une
expression à sion qui s'est arrêtée il
ya une commission d'enquêté
bien sûr il est aujourd'hui on doit
poursuivre ce travail sera une autre et
ses danses et c'est dans ce cadre là
c'est intéressant ce que l'hybride c'est
réactiver ou celle des autres
ah c'est une autre amie la mission est
close mais en fait vous savez tout le
problème de cette mission c'était quoi
c'était que on était en train de tirer
des conséquences
alors d'une crise alors que la crise
n'était pas terminée bien dire là on
peut penser que d'ici six mois elle sera
terminée
qu'est ce qu'il faut penser pour le
futur c'est comment un peu comme dans
les grandes entreprises
il ya des services qui sont spécialisés
dans le management du changement il ya
des des personnes qui sont capables de
travailler en mode projet
quand on est face à une crise et que les
procédures dans ce cas là doivent être
nouvelle comment on fait pour être
meilleur bien plus réactif sur table
plusieurs ministres sont contaminés
aujourd'hui le cadre roselyne bachelot
notamment fait polémique
elle a été prise en photo avec des
artistes non masqué après une
représentation à l'opéra
est ce que pour vous il a manqué de
prudence je peut coûter moi j'ai une
copine au mois de décembre
donc peut-être que j'ai été prudent
aussi vous parler des masques oui il
faut consomme à ce qu'il faut surtout
qu'on évite les interactions sociales et
dans des lieux fermés quand même culture
les toscans mais savez vous avez aussi
des personnes qui mettent le masque tout
le temps pis qui ont le coup vite quand
même parce qu'il se retrouver dans un
lieu clos ou fermée et puis après vous
on avait d'autres qui au contraire ne
met pas de masque mais se retrouve
suffisamment éloignés les uns des autres
où suffisamment à l'air libre pour que
ça passe moi je vais pas dire ça fait
quand même mais je vais vous dire dans
votre question oui il y aurait quelque
chose de drôle à ce qu'un président de
groupe de la majorité disent que une
ministre l a pas pris ses précautions
comme il faut et c'est pour ça qu'elle
est le co vite mais ça voudrait dire
quoi ça voudrait dire que j'envoie un
message à nos concitoyens qui nous
regardent que quand ils ont le comité
c'est de leur faute
non quand on a le coc vide c'est pas de
votre faute
c'est aujourd'hui on est touché de la
photo qui fait polémique se fait à ce
qu'elle soit avec des personnes non
m'assieds c'est ça qui peut faire
polémique
après qu'elle ait attrapé le couesnon
réseaux sociaux et de chaînes
d'information n'importe quelle photo
toutes les semaines où vous pourrez
expliquer que c'est toujours la faute
des uns et des autres moi je pense que
face à un problème faut pas trouver le
coupable faut trouver des abus sur les
commerces oui les commerces non
essentiel donc sont fermés les tpe qui
font moins d'un million de chiffre
d'affaires réclament des aides
supplémentaires faut-il et leur a
accordé par exemple certains parlent de
l'effacement de leurs dettes alors vous
avez deux sujets sur le les tpe
il ya la question du statut du dirigeant
d'entreprise
parce que aujourd'hui un accompagnement
des salariés c'est heureux il ya un
fonds de solidarité pour les entreprises
en particulier les plus petites ce fonds
solidarité permet de faire face à ses
charges courantes
le loyer l'eau l'électricité les fluides
dont on connaît ça mais celui qui a pris
les risques celui qui est à la tête de
l'entreprise et qui parfois depuis un an
a du mal à travailler à se faire achaler
pour lui-même
celui-là n'est pas accompagnée et si
demain son entreprise disparaît il
n'aura pas non plus alors complètement
ce qu'il n'y a pas d'assurances
finalement parce que c'est la question
en fait de d'une garantie d'assurance
chômage pour les chefs d'entreprise que
les chefs d'entreprise dans les plus
petites entreprises puissent être
accompagnés dans ce moment où c'est pas
de leur faute s'ils ont dû abandonner
leur activité
c'est parce que naturellement leur
commerce avait été frigitt
vous vous êtes attaché dans votre partie
à la dette notamment
est ce que le quoi qu'il en coûte à des
limites pour vous est ce qu'il faut
penser à résorber cette dette il peut
pas avoir de limites
parce que si vous ne la compagne mpa
l'économie française aujourd'hui ça
coûtera plus cher demain et donc si vous
êtes favorable à ce que la france ne
s'endette pas trop il faut surtout
penser que dans la décennie qui vient
si l'économie françaises s'effondraient
nous mettrions de la dette sur les
épaules de nos enfants plus encore et
donc ne concevons pas les efforts très
importants que nous faisons pour
soutenir l'économie comme simplement de
la dette comme de l'argent public qui
nous faudra rembourser
mais au contraire comme une façon de se
sauver c'est un investissement pour que
ça nous coûte pas plus cher de
prohibition c'est une idée qui est celle
de faire participer une contribution en
fait des plus aisés est-ce que vous
pensez que il faut aller plus loin porté
cette idée au parlement et est ce que
vous allez le faire dans le prochain
budget par exemple je crois que
aujourd'hui il faut qu'on arrive à
doubler ce plan de relance et quand on
est passé de 100 à 200 milliards
quand on s'adresse quand on s'adresse
aux plus aisés on leur dit quoi on leur
dit qu'on a besoin qu'ils mettent leur
épargne qui mettent leur argent dans
l'économie française et donc sans
forcément les surtaxer leur dire que cet
argent vous en rendez compte les
français ont mis plus de 100 milliards
des pagnes de côté depuis un an ce sont
les plus âgés si cela en est capable
demain avec les journées plus aisé de
plus réinvestir féminin conomie
française on a un plan de l'état 200
milliards et on pourrait avoir un plan
attribue les français les plus aisés 200
milliards de taxes la taxe sur les plus
aisés
oui enfin mots j'ai toujours été clair
sur le fait que je considère qu'il ya
une épargne dormantes
mais répondait mois pas de taxe sur les
plus aisés je me sens bien compris à un
moment il faudra mettre une taxe sur
l'épargné dormantes et si celle ci reste
à dormir bien ta main d'oeuvre qu'est ce
qu'ils ont peut-être puisqu'on parlait
de d'écologie tout à l'heure sur le
projet toi qui m'as et oui sur le projet
de loi climat l'éco taxe pourrait
revenir par région dans ce projet de loi
climat ce que pour vous c'est le bon
monde pour relancer ça alors que ça
pourrait peut-être réactiver le
mouvement d'aidé gilet jaune un léger
les jaunes dont on a aujourd'hui un pro
des tendances pour s'éviter
après les bonnets rouges eux les gilet
jaune qu'on s'invente pas lé manteau
orange ont d'abord il faut pas dire
qu'on veut rétablir la taxe carbone il
ya la possibilité laissée aux conseils
régionaux d'expérimentation dans chaque
région d'une taxe spécifique en
particulier sur les véhicules des plus
polluants et on pense en particulier aux
poids lourds étrangers qui souvent
région ça leur permet de le faire mais
regardons les choses en face
dans notre économie si nous voulons
vraiment faire la mutation écologique
nous avons besoin de fixer un prix au
carbone c'est évident alors par exemple
mais vous compte les décisions
favorables
moi je pense que vous avez des
transports internationaux en auvergne
rhône-alpes qui si demain était un peu
plus taxés nous aurions la capacité de
financer le fret ferroviaire
les lignes lui en tueur vous seriez pour
une connaissance auvergne rhône-alpes
mais moi je pense que aujourd'hui si
laurent wauquiez veut mettre un milliard
comme ils l'annoncent dans le lyon turin
pour faire du fret ferroviaire il faudra
qu'il trouve des ressources
alors comment le faire l'écotaxe pour
que ce soit juste quand on parle
d'argent c'est très important
humainement fait ce qu'on aide les
cortex et le temps vous créer une
fiscalité écologique vous baisser la
fiscalité traditionnel à même hauteur
si vous faites plus sans de fiscalité
écologique vous baisser la fiscalité
traditionnels en faisant moins ce qu'est
ce que vous souhaitez en rhône alpes
et là vous faites une fiscalité plus
élevée c'est ce que voulait faire ce que
je souhaite mais comme vous voulez
constater je suis pas président mais
c'est ce que vous souhaiteriez vous
pouvez merci brigitta parce que le temps
passe très vite
merci beaucoup avec une centaine d'élus
vous êtes prononcé pour le droit de vote
à saison aux municipales dès l'âge de 16
ans et leur journal du dimanche et hier
c'est quoi le message le message c'est
qu'il faut ne fermer aucune porte
pour revitaliser la démocratie dans
notre pays on sait que les jeunes et oui
il y avait l
aux dernières élections nationales 55 %
des jeunes qui n'étaient pas allés voter
et donc mon collègue david corceiro à
travailler sur toute une série de
mesures sur l'engagement associatif sur
l'engagement humanitaire et le message
c'est il faut qu'on réapprenne la
citoyenneté il faut que nos enfants
retrouvent l'envié d'aller voler à 16
ans vous pensez qu'ils auront envie
d'aller voter parce que sont les
élections municipales pensais pas qu'il
serait plus intéressé par la présidence
on parle elle me manque parce que c'est
après la république c'est vous pouvez
vous pouvez vouloir une révolution
répond très précisément si vous leur
dites vous avez le droit de voter à 16
ans mais seulement pour la
présidentielle vous êtes obligés de
faire des modifications très profonde du
code pénal pour elle du code pénal il
faudrait ensuite aligné parce que ça
deviendrait une majorité au sens plein
du terme d'accor et donc faudrait
modifier le code en l'occurrence donner
la possibilité à des jeunes de voter dès
16 ans pour choisir leur maire pour
qu'ensuite qu'ils apprennent ce à aller
voter ou démocratique ce goût d'aller
voter de sortir de chez soi pour décider
un peu de son avenir
eh ben ça leur permettra peut-être ça
fait partie d'une des multiples peu
silence et que ça verra le jour ce à
venir à moi je pense que on y viendra où
se côtoient dans ce quinquennat pas dans
ce cas qu'est la d6 pendant ce
quinquennat
non non mais on a bien compris qu'il y
avait un certain nombre de réformes
institutionnelles qui allait devoir
faire l'objet d'une vaste réforme à
thiers de la dictature prochaine on a
cas humains non yves thréard lycées
directeur d'un des filières ou bonsoir
bonsoir francis bonsoir patrick mignola
les frères alors on regarde on observe
la vie du modem et on se dit que le
modem ans mort noyé dans une zone de
turbulences parce que vis-à-vis de la
majorité présidentielle et du président
de la république il ya beaucoup de
thèmes qui n'avance pas et qui vous sont
chers parce qu'il ya des élections
régionales et que vous avez du mal à
trouver un point d'équilibré
on va reparler des régionales mais
d'abord sur les thèmes françois bayrou
qui est vraiment l'homme qui a réussi
d'ailleurs à faire élire le président de
la république en tient pour la
proportionnelle et là dessus le
président de la république semble avoir
complètement mis ça de côté
comme d'ailleurs la banque de la
démocratie ou sonné c'était aussi 10 et
de françois bayrou
comme vous en avez parlé tout à l'heure
le plan le doublement du plan de relance
vous n'êtes pas un peu vix est quand
même et maltraités il faut jamais mettre
d'amour-propre dans la vie politique
sinon sinon on s'arrête tout de suite de
faire ça mais le sujet institutionnel
est un sujet sur lequel malheureusement
on n'a pas pu avancer parce que il s'est
abîmé au cours d'un été avec le avec la
sphère benalla alors que cette majorité
s'apprêtait à prendre des décisions qui
était fondamental réduction du nombre de
députés
ainsi la scion d'une dose de
proportionnelle est aujourd'hui moi je
crois pas que ce soit le président de la
république est fermé la porte pour le
mans ce sont les parlementaires qui ont
fermé la porte parce que vraiment les
parlementaires la majorité attention
d'acronis parce que le alors les
républicains le parti socialiste était
majoritairement opposés et de toute
façon il fallait quand même que la
majorité trouvent une voie en
l'occurrence christophe castaner olivier
vachon vraiment travailler ils ont bossé
avec les députés
mais il y avait dès lors qu'on n'était
plus sur la version initiale du
président de la république c'est la
réduction du nombre de parlementaires et
une dose de proportionnelle corps
nécessité un redécoupage
mais vous avez il avait autant de
versions qu'il y avait toujours autant
faut pas perdre le but batterie guyanais
artistement sousse et c'est la voie
parlementaire fait un clin mais c'est
exactement la proposition de françois
bayrou et je ne doute pas un instant
qu'il n'abandonnera pas son combat parce
que là sinon s'il n'a pas ceux ci ne
gagne pas ce combat là françois bayrou
haut commissaire de la république on
entend peu parler de lui il a du mal à
se faire entendre à se faire des
propositions comme un vis-à-vis auprès
du président de la république au jeu je
crois pas moi je vous savez dans le
dénouement de la crise des lignes de
gilet jaune puis dans l'élaboration du
plan de relance puis dans ce que nous
avons écrit sur le la vie etc locaux
vides françois bayrou fait progresser
des idées mais aujourd'hui il n'est pas
dans une situation où il veut exister
pour exister il veut être influent pour
être utile aux français
françois est passé dans ce moment de sa
vie et je pense que c'est précieux pour
la vie politique et que c'est loin
d'être désagréable pour lui il est passé
dans ce moment où ils préfèrent faire
bouger les choses que valoriser sa
personnalité ce qu il est clair qu'on
est après 1 en un peu plus d'un peu
moins d'un an un peu plus d'un an de
l'élection présidentielle que françois
bayrou qui a été déjà candidats trois
fois cette élection sera derrière le
président de la république si celui ci
se représente c'est moi je je vois qu'il
ya beaucoup de si dans votre question
mais je pour moi vous dire ça je vois
une relation entre les deux hommes clé
une relation empreinte de respect
d'amitié d'admiration et de conversation
très constructive dans un moment
difficile parce le pays et donc pour
répandre l'imaginerait pas je
n'imaginerais pas que emmanuel macron ne
continue pas de s'appuyer sur françois
bayrou comme richard ferrand comme
christophe castaner comme toutes ces
personnalités qui au fond fabrique au
quotidien ce que nous sommes
alors il vous a pas échappé qu'il ya
quelques semaines il ya quelques
semaines avec le président de la
république dans un entretien site
internet qui s'appelle brut a dit si
jamais je ne suis pas en mesure de me
représenter ce qui avait surpris tout le
monde derrière je ne me représenterai
pas est ce que à ce moment là françois
bayrou serait le recours il pourrait
l'être il fait partie des leaders
naturels de la majorité présidentielle
dans coup de oui il en a la capacité il
a surtout cette qualité formidable de
ressentir l'opinion publique on peut
être en accord ou en désaccord avec lui
mais il a cette qualité principale dans
la vie politique française de ressentir
le bon sens populaire de ressentir un
certain nombre d'attentes profonde
donc oui évidemment il peut faire partie
des leaders naturels et recours vous
ayez le ferai et il a le sens du devoir
il/elle sens du devoir je crois surtout
qu'il a il a envie parce qu'il s'est
battu pour faire survivre cette grande
famille centrale dans la vie politique
française qui n'est plus centriste qui
est centrale pour la faire
vivre ensuite maintenant il a envie
évidemment de la pérenniser central
seulement le dans cette vaste majorité
centrale voilà que j'avais un courant
centriste
on veut dire qu'elle autorise celle
votre lenôtre accor mais il est pas
exclusif
alors que naturellement il doit
continuer de ses larges il ya dans d'ici
à quelques semaines
il des élections régionales deuxième
quinzaine du mois de juin
d'abord est-ce que vous êtes attaché à
son maintien il ya eu un appel de dix
présidents de conseils régionaux en
figaro de droite voulait devenir ce
qu'ils ont dit il faut que ces élections
aient lieu
vous êtes sur cette longueur d'onde
enfin moi je pense que c'est toujours
difficile de de décaler les dates
d'élections alors je suis favorable mais
pas pour les mêmes raisons que j'ai bien
compris que c'est quand vous êtes
président de région sortant y avait pas
de modem dedans et que vous serrez les
dents parce qu'il ya pas encore de
président de région modem j'espère bien
que geneviève darrieussecq et marc
chesneau vont arranger ça dans les
quelques mois qui viennent mais vous
avez des sortants qui se disent au fond
qu'il faut tenir les élections parce que
c'est le bon sens démocratique dont acte
ils savent aussi fait de la politique et
savez ce qui s'écrit dans votre
excellent journal que au fond si on est
en période de crise sanitaire et qu' il
ya des conditions difficiles pour faire
campagne
et puis qu'ensuite il ya peu de
participation ils ont d'autant plus de
chances d'être réélu
donc je pense que cet appel dans vos
colonnes n'est pas tout à fait dénué
d'arrières oui mais vous dites quand il
faut les lire dérangère lithiques cet
appel
bien sûr il n'est pas démocratique il
est politique je confirme je crois qu'il
est un peu démocratique mais qui n'est
pas dénué de calcul politique alors le
modem c'est pour ça que je disais qu'il
y avait une zone de turbulences et que
beaucoup de conseils régionaux provence
alpes côte d'azur ile de france haute
france d'ailleurs
il ya des conseillers régionaux modem
qui ont dit qu'ils allaient continuer à
suivre la majorité le président sortant
en l'occurrence qui est l air ou de
droite en tous les cas
est ce que vous allez les exclure de
votre mouvement sinon conseils régionaux
on procède jamais par l'exclusion s'est
jamais arrivé aujourd'hui on n'a jamais
on n'a jamais
sauf pour vraiment des raisons de
discipline où tout fait feu jazz a dû
arriver une fois ou deux mais on
n'exclut pas par principe mais si on
peut s'arrêter là dessus un instant
c'est pas par calcul c'est pas en se
disant qu'on va faire élire quelques
modem sur la liste des présidents
sortant et d'autres modem plus nombreux
sur les listes de la majorité
présidentielle
parce que vous savez si d'aventuré il
doit y avoir diffusion d'entre deux
tours par définition ce qui sont avec
les présidents de région sortants seront
les premiers sortis lors de la fusion
c'est simplement parce que on n'aime pas
procéder par par procès staliniens il y
en a certains que je comprends au fond
ça fait six ans qu'ils ont travaillé
yann wehrling part exacte une figure qui
contredit de france il se dit j'ai
travaillé pendant six ans et valérie
pécresse jeux géants j'ai envie de
travailler de continuer à travailler
avec elle ça peut s'entraîner 18 mai
parce que yann wehrling est une
personnalité politique était secrétaire
nationale des verts qui a été secrétaire
général du modem lui je le comprends un
peu moins que les autres
ah parce qu'il sait très bien que ça a
un impact qui fait c'est entre les
exemples c'est en train d'abîmer au fond
la majorité présidentielle et entraînant
avec lui cinq ou six autres peut-être qu
il les condamne à neutre pas élu donc je
pense que pour la famille politique que
je représente et pour ces personnes qui
sont mes amis je pense qu'il a fait un
mauvais choix
il a fait un mauvais une dernière
question voilier dernière mais savez on
parle beaucoup de lui front républicain
si d'aventuré il y avait trois listes au
deuxième tour dans un an ici ou là dans
quelques régions et que vous soyez sur
la troisième liste troisième par exemple
notamment avec la majorité
présidentielle
est-ce qu'il faut vous retirer pour
empêcher et faire barrage au
rassemblement national je pense que il
faudra par tous est nécessaire faire
évidemment barrage au front national
dont je dis bon je déteste que
ils essayent de continuer sa
dédiabolisation ce sera jamais un parti
politique comme les autres mais on peut
aussi le faire
en fusionnant plutôt que en se retirant
pourquoi quand on travaille sur les
élections locales faut faire des
rassemblements et il faut pouvoir se
dire on peut être différent mais pour
travailler au service d'une région au
service d'un département on peut
travailler ensemble merci merci beaucoup
on va maintenant tout à l'heure à
cueillir de parlementaires qui vont
débattre avec vous mais d'abord une
question sur le 8 avril vous savez ce
jour là il y aurait une proposition de
loi à l'assemblée nationale pour
autoriser l'euthanasie en france un
sujet sensible question simple réponse
simple quelle sera la position des
modèles la liberté de vote parce que sur
tous les sujets de société la liberté de
vote et vous moi à titre personnel
j'y suis personnellement favorable
politiquement très défavorable
personnellement favorable parce qu'au
fond comme tous les français je préfère
mourir dans la dignité que dans
l'indignité et j'ai envie que ces sujets
qui sont des sujets dont on peut parler
tous les jours soit évidemment évoqué en
revanche je pense que c'est un sujet qui
peut profondément divisé la société
française au moment où on a déjà même
pas appliquer la loi précédente le
moment de le faire
régis à parlementaire s'est pacsé pole
man c'est que c'est le moment
d'appliquer la loi précédente à cordes
et l'autre laisse leonetti elle est même
pas appliqué à 50 % il ya 12 % des
français qui ont fait aujourd'hui leurs
directives anticipées cercle qui ont
écrit un papier disant ce qu'ils veulent
et quand ils arriveront en fin de vie 12
% c augmente de 12% par an si on
accélère pas sur la loi que l'ess
leonetti elle sera appliquée dans 45 ans
des dons dans l'ordre
appliquons les lois avant de 200
sédimentation successives ratant je
n'étais pas content on va maintenant
accueillir les deux parlementaires qui
vont débattre avec vous
[Musique]
et donc ces deux parlementaires sont
esther benbassa et robin reda qui nous
ont rejoints sur ce plateau bonsoir à
tous les deux merci d'être ici je vais
vous présenter un parent à esther
benbassa vous êtes sénatrice europe
ecologie les verts de paris vice
présidente du tout nouveau on va dire
encore récent groupe écologiste au sénat
et robin reda vous êtes-vous député
l'est républicain de l'essonne et
apparentés parce que vous êtes membre de
libre qui est le parti de valérie
pécresse ce qui ce qui est une nuance
supplémentaires à droite et vous vouliez
tous les deux évoqué avec patrick
mignola on va peut-être commencer par là
ça vous irait très vite
roberdam sur l'unef l'islamo gauchisme
et toutes ces questions qui sont au
coeur de l'actualité peut-être au vert
et d'acquis vous commencez un je sais
pas alors robert et la visite et vous
irez dans la conversation
merci bonjour monsieur le président cher
cher patrick mignola moi je voulais
aborder effectivement avec vous une
sujet un sujet qui est important et dont
nous avons débattu déjà l'assemblée
nationale il y a quelques semaines et
qui a réactivé avec la polémique autour
du syndicat étudiant l'unef dont la
présidente a reconnu avoir organisé avec
ce syndicat étudiant des réunions du
tour non mixité soit réservé aux femmes
soient réservés à des publics elle
appellera 6 et c'est à dire en gros les
personnes non blanches
je crois que nous sommes et nous sommes
beaucoup à le penser peut-être nous
sommes dans une dérive que l'on appelle
racialiste c'est à dire de personnes et
en particulier chez les jeunes qui au
prétexte de lutter contre les
discriminations réactive des luttes et à
défaut de lutte des classes réactive une
forme de lutte des races dans la société
à l'assemblée nationale avec mon
président groupe damien abad avec un
ensemble de députés les républicains
nous avions demandé au président et cher
ferrand il ya quelques semaines de créer
une mission d'information de mission de
requêtes de l'assemblée nationale sur
les dérives du des colonialismes 2
l'identité racialiste à l'université
pour le moment cette demande elle est
restée lettre morte de la part du
président de l'assemblée nationale je
voulais savoir si en tant que président
de groupe du modem vous seriez d'accord
pour réactiver cette demande pour que
les parlementaires se saisissent de ce
qui sape s'apparente à une dérive à la
fois dans le milieu universitaire le
milieu scolaire le milieu étudiant je
vous répondais pied sert de l'alba sari
rebondira parce qu'elle n'a pas évident
avant le même point de vue oui bon je
suis favorable évidemment et puis de
toute façon chaque groupe dont le vôtre
inde sur redd a bien sûr peut demander
des commissions d enquête parlementaire
c'est un sujet important mais je ferais
presque la distinction entre ce que ce
qu'on a vu de l'unef et qui doit faire
l'objet pour moi d'une réaction de la
part du gouvernement ou de la part des
mairies
il ya une loi qui s'applique moi j'ai
une boussole c'est la loi gayssot
c'est la loi contre le racisme celle de
1986 s'il est avéré et ça paraît assez
évident puisque ça a été avoué en tant
que tels que l'unef a utilisé des
réflexes des méthodes des procédures qui
peuvent s'apparenter à du racisme dans
ce cas là il faudra en tirer toutes les
conséquences après quelques concerts
seront toutes les questions moi je pense
que c'est très compliqué de continuer à
financer par du financement public
directe ou indirecte en mettant des
salles à disposition ou en versant des
subventions une association étudiante
dont le but normalement et de travailler
au service des étudiants mais qui en
l'occurrence à un ressort qui est un
ressort politique qui pourrait réactiver
le racisme on ne va pas être d'accord
mais vous savez les réunions non mixtes
ont commencé en france dans les années
1970 le mlf est né dans cette mouvance
c'était des réunions de parole des
changes entre femmes qui pouvaient
s'exprimer mieux
plus facilement lorsqu'il n'y avait pas
les hommes
et comme vous le savez la parole c'est
le pouvoir
enfin on va pas faire maintenant de la
psychanalyse elle néanmoins
ces réunions ont donné naissance au
mouvement féministe
pour ce qui concerne l'unaf
ces réunions n'était pas seulement
racialisée savoir que des femmes
blanches aussi blanche entre guillemets
parce que j'aime pas ce mot blanche mais
ayant besoin de se réunir ou sujettes à
au sexisme des lgbt qui pouvait être de
peau blanche sujet à l'homophobie et il
y à savoir qu'on ne peut pas seulement
mettre en avant cette racialisation
parce que là ça serait une erreur et
deuxièmement je suis professeur
d'université
écoutez ce n'est pas le moment
lorsque nos étudiants sont en détresse
en détresse alimentaire en détresse de
toutes sortes
essayez de de focaliser sur cette
question parce que ça c'est ce genre de
choses y compris l'islamo gauchisme sa
déshonneur l'université les
universitaires et les étudiants
je vais vous poser cette question
sincèrement monsieur pensez-vous qu'en
qu'en essayant d'arrêter la pensée la
réflexion le la diversité à l'université
des réflexions de la pensée on va
arriver à quelque chose il ya des
dérives bien sûr il n'y a pas de dérive
mais ce n'est pas que ça ce n'est pas
que ça mais aussi la pauvreté nomen qui
va un jour créer une sorte de géorgie
même alors aucun ya aussi la pauvreté la
précarité étudiante 10 esther benbassa
eelv avait parfaitement raison est
d'ailleurs l'une est fort et mieux de
s'occuper de la détresse étudiante
plutôt qu'essayer de mettre en scène
en réalité ce type de dérive parce que
vous avez raison au fond il ya parfois
besoin de se retrouver en comité plus
restreint ou en comité plus
confidentielle pour que la parole se
libère
et vous avez parfaitement raison de le
dire mais en l'occurrence la présidente
de l'unef est venu sur une grande radio
à matin pour expliquer valoriser et
exploiter politiques pensent qu'elle
faisait et sait parfaitement ce qu'elle
faisait
ce faisant à sa décharge dirait qu'elle
a été longuement interrogé lâcher mais
bon je le dis en tant que journaliste
qui vous permettez des jeux j'ai vécu
immerge moi j'ai envie de vous poser une
question parce que tous les débats
doivent être ouverts à l'université dans
la limite de la loi de ce que fixe aloi
boussole loi gayssot dont les sujets
peuvent être ouverts mais demain vous
n'aurez pas le droit et heureusement
c'est l'honneur de la france d'ouvrir un
débat sur le révisionnisme ou un débat
raciste et encore heureux c'est
précisément pour ça comme ceux de tous
des lois mais j'ai envie de vous poser
une question qu'est ce que c'est être
racialisée faire une réunion où les non
blancs ne serait pas là c'est à partir
de quel pourcentage de non blancs qu'on
peut exclure quelqu'un ne réunit alors
oui touché dire on est quasiment dans
les lois des années 30 aux examens
publics n avons combattu alors alors on
va pas l'approcher le ce qui s'est passé
à lunel avec le fascisme c'est un des
seuls les gens chantent en choeur oui
parfum monsieur blanc qu'elle s'est pas
sa parole n'est pas sacralisé quand même
on peut la critiquer participer aux
réunions du chef
oui moi je suis désolé mon papa était
orphelin je sais pas remonter jusqu'à
mon grand-père est ce que j'ai un
pourcentage de non blancs suffisant pour
aller dans une réunion l'unef
d'accord il faut il faut pas s'arrêter
sur ce mot d'ailleurs le mot blanc ne me
convient pas ça veut dire que cette il
faut dire bon il ya des gens qui sont
racialisées l'acia lisez c'est quoi
c'est par exemple j'exagère être femme
et noire est lesbienne disons ce moment
là vous avez le prototype de la personne
masia lisait c'est vrai que tout cela
vient
des universités américaines où la
politique a été remplacé par ces
questions j'ai enseigné j'ai été dans
plusieurs universités américaines
il y a eu des exagérations il faut pas
arriver à cela ça c'est vraiment dommage
tu es ce que nos jeunes font de la
politique
il ne s'attend pas que sous ce que sur
ça mais il ne faut pas non plus dit abu
lisez faire la chasse aux sorcières
parce que les étudiants les enseignants
ont besoin du rsa d'engrais aussi vous
écoute il veut réagir à vos propos et
après on va relancer le débat à la fois
une réaction est plus une
une question que j'ai envie de poser
presque à tous les deux sur le plateau
la première c'est que ce qu'évoque
esther benbassa je suis évidemment
radicalement contre cette conception
dite de l'intersexualité c'est à dire du
cumul du cumul des dix ans d'écart pour
absolument jouer sur le sentiment
victimaire moi j'en peux plus de cette
société où on veut absolument créer des
victimes alors qu'il faudrait que l'on
crée notamment dans un modèle de
méritocratie républicaine des nouveaux
héros des gens qui ont envie de porter
leurs différences et elles peuvent
exister y compris dans la république
mais qui ne se réduisent pas à leur
couleur de peau est leur origine leur
religion ou à leur genre ensuite la
question j'ai envie de poser c'est est
ce qu'on est toujours à l'aise en france
avec le modèle universaliste républicain
qui ne reconnaît que des êtres humains
que des citoyens libres et qui ne classe
pas les gens fonctionnent justement de
l'origine de leurs communautés y compris
le président de la république et une
partie de sa majorité n'ont pas été à
l'aise sur cette question là pendant
toute la première partie du quinquennat
jusqu'à ce que le fameux discours des
mureaux viennent un peu soldé la
question avec une position
présidentielle un peu plus franche sur
la question des communautarismes qui
n'ont pas à s'exprimer dans la
république est un souhait non avérées
d'importer des modèles anglo-saxons et
je crois qu'il faut nous prémunir de ça
en relançant une politique anti raciste
et il faut l'assumer en france
universaliste c'est à dire qui qui qui
lutte contre toutes les discriminations
sans exception et sans donner des sortes
de davantage aux uns et aux autres en
fonction de leurs origines mignola et
que l'on combat très fortement le modèle
anglo saxon qui est une tentation à la
fois chez les libéraux
de la majorité des manuels macro et bien
sûr ch
c'est la gauche le plus raté qui a three
mignola il ya les etats-unis aussi un
peu c'est du mouvement intellectuel
moi je suis contre toutes les formes de
communautarisme que je crois pas que la
république telle qu'elle a été conçue en
france en fait être français c'est plus
un destin que avoir une religion
appartenir à une ethnie ou parfois même
partagé une langue parce qu'on peut
avoir des langues différentes et une
tentation y compris même au sein de la
majorité
alors moi je crois que la majorité très
à l'aise sur ce sujet à une distinction
près avec ce que vous dites monsieur
reda et auquel je souscris globalement
c'est que je pense pas qu'il faille
aller chercher des prétextes mémorielle
pour nous diviser
c'est sûr en revanche nous sommes
obligés de reconnaître que nous vivons
dans une société où si vous n'êtes pas
né au bon endroit
si vous n'avez pas le bon nom si vous
n'avez pas la bonne allure
la manière de vous déplacer ou de vous
habiller
si vous n'avez pas autant de sous que
les autres vous avez moins de chance lé
code si on arrive à l'école c'est ça en
fait
ussel c'est plus dur d'aller faire
d'aller faire sciences po et de devenir
un nouveau héros de la république
si vous avez été élu dans un quartier
difficile de chambéry et je pense que
c'est assez jeune la clé pas seulement
seine-saint-denis pour justement on
exactement vous avez des jeunes ainsi
dans la ruralité qui sont dans cette
difficulté est au fond ce que vous dites
l'un et l'autre se retrouvent vous
prenez des chemins différents pour le
dire mais qu'est ce qu'on cherche tous
on cherche à atteindre une égalité
réelle dans cette société
or quand certains partent avec 5 ou 7
mètres de retard sur les autres pour
courir le 100 m c'est beaucoup plus
difficile est en fait c'est vers eux que
toute notre action publique doit tendre
bien on vous voulez un petit mot
très rapidement vous parler de
communautarisme
écoutez quand des femmes se réunissent
elles font pas du communautarisme c'est
quoi le communautarisme des femmes 50%
de la population mondiale
le communautarisme des femmes c'est un
peu difficile dans notre arbitre central
gens écoutent avec attention tous réunis
en savoyard gérons n'est pas
communautaire
vous êtes d'accord avec cette même une
sénatrice ça vous vouliez parler du
projet de loi climat voilà patrick
mignola je vous laisse intervenir comme
vous le savez le texte climat lézignan
s'est passé des gens commission spéciale
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
n'est pas très satisfaite du texte étant
donné qu'elle craint que la mise en
place des mesures parce qu'il ya des
bonnes mesures aussi dans ce texte
ne puisse pas réduire la de 40 % en 2030
l'émission de gaz à effet de serre
puisque comme vous le savez on est en
décalage est l'europe s'est déclaré pour
55 % en 2000 en 2030
l'autre question est en raison du pacte
vert européen
alors moi je vous pose une question vous
qui êtes au modem un parti honorable
qu'est ce que vous comptez faire pour
accélérer la transition écologique en
prenant en considération la situation
économique et sociale actuelle et ne pas
laisser faire de cette loi une demi loi
comme le craignent les écolos chaque
niveau
je crois qu'il ya deux priorités la
première priorité c'est justement comme
vous venez de le dire
compte tenu de la situation économique
et sociale profiter du plan de relance
pour qu'ils aient une priorité
principale c'est le verdissement de
l'économie
celle-ci demain toutes les entreprises
de france peuvent bénéficier d'une
énergie décarbonée ce qui signifie et là
nous allons différé que à mes yeux il
faut maintenir une filière nucléaire en
france
parce que de toute façon pour les 30 ans
qui viennent nous voyons bien qu on aura
toujours besoin du nucléaire pour
obtenir une énergie décarbonée
c'est une chance absolument
extraordinaire jusqu'à ce que d'autres
énergies que l'hydrogène que c'est le
les énergies renouvelables puissent être
développés ça c'est la première chose
puis la deuxième chose je l' ai dit tout
à l'heure en un mot je pense vraiment
qu'on a besoin d'une fiscalité
écologique et nous devons la construire
tous les parlementaires ensemble à
l'écouté et senna ensemble ces temps que
vous fixez pas un prix au carbone
de toute façon vous ne lutteraient pas
pour la décarbonation de l'économie et
moi je pense qu'il faut baisser les
impôts traditionnelle et augmenter les
impôts écologique et c'est comme ça
qu'on s'en sortira pas ce que c'est ça
la seule voix vous l'entendez bien fait
mais pas la seule n'est ce pas
l'énergie est une solution intermédiaire
puis il faudrait passer aux énergies non
fossiles
il faut qu'on s'attelle aussi plus
activement à la rénovation des bâtiments
l'alimentation un chèque alimentation
pour qu'on puisse manger bio h et
alimentation est porté par une député
modem violaine de cours sont bons les
résultats
robert reda vous voulez vous revenir sur
la proportionnelle parce que je disais
tout à l'heure qui avait peut-être pas
beaucoup de gens contre messi avait
l'air vous êtes contre et voulu en
parler avec patrick vignal
je conviens que il ya que les
républicains qui s'honore remuer un peu
le couteau dans la plaie même si j'ai
bien compris que c'est un débat que nous
aurons probablement à l'échelle
nationale l'année prochaine et je sais
que c'est une proposition de longue date
du modem et de monsieur bayrou
moi je me suis engagé en politique à 16
ans je me suis engagé en politique pour
la france pour mes idées aussi mes
convictions dans mon parti politique de
l'époque l'ump mais surtout pour
rencontrer des françaises et des
français pour rencontrer modestement les
habitants de ma ville et ensuite les
habitants de la circonscription
je crois fondamentalement que les lui
doit être connectée au terrain et que ce
qui reste de proximité après la loi sur
le non-cumul des mandats qui a
profondément déconnecté on l'a vu sur
cette législature
les parlementaires les députés de leur
terrain électoral ce qui reste de cette
proximité doit être préservé et c'est là
où le scrutin majoritaire continue à mon
sens d'être un scrutin important s'il ya
un lien direct entre les lecteurs et le
candidat soit
on a ainsi une dose de proportionnelle
comme vous le proposez ça ne change
quasiment rien au profil de l'assemblée
nationale soit on passe dans la
proportionnelle intégrale tels que veut
le faire in extremis monsieur bayrou
soit disant par référendum et on change
totalement de régime politique avec des
risques qui à mon avis n'accroîtront pas
la représenter en mobilité des français
parce que les français ne se lève pas le
matin en visant à défendre les positions
du bureau politique de la veille de l
ère du ps modem
donc est ce que vous pensez vraiment que
cette proportionnelle c'est une affaire
de représentativité des français à
l'assemblée nationale où une affaire de
représentativité du modem dans n'importe
quelle majorité assistant dans le pays
la question est bien posée mais je veux
pas la prendre sous l'angle le mode amis
c'est évidemment le sujet c'est le lien
avec la population c'est ce lien charnel
con qu'on doit avoir avec nos électeurs
sinon c'est pas c'est pas intéressant de
faire de la politique je crois pas du
tout que la proportionnelle empêche le
lien moi j'ai été élu maire dans un
scrutin proportionnel avec prime 1 j'ai
été élu conseiller régional dans un
scrutin proportionnel avec prime je
constate que les sénateurs sont élus aux
trois quarts à l'élection
proportionnelle et je ferai jamais gardé
le procès des élus aux sénateurs ne pas
être en proximité
pas seulement avec les élus y compris et
que la population c'est les gens sont
très contents quand il voit arriver un
sénateur dans une manifestation
parce qu'ils sont eux en face d'un
parlementaire ils peuvent échanger avec
lui et rochon en 1986 vous ne pouvez pas
vous en souvenir monsieur reda mais à
l'époque ça
voulait se dire et à l'époque en 1986 ce
lien direct dans mon petit département
de la savoie
il était réel parce qu'il y avait des
parlementaires qui étaient accrochés à
leur territoire
c'est au fond la proportionnelle ça sert
surtout à une chose ça nous oblige à
nous comporter différemment au niveau
national à être capables de construire
des majorités des projets ensemble à ce
regard des liens ferment pourquoi alors
que souvent quand je vous entends parler
dans l'hémicycle jude accord avec 90% de
ce que vous dites pourquoi j'ai pas le
droit de le dire pourquoi on n'a pas le
droit de travailler ensemble pour bâtir
des majorités ensemble critiquant le
ralliement de monsieur wehrling mais mme
pécresse les jambes
non parce que parce que yann vous savez
vous savez bien il ya nos fonds il avait
envie de travailler avec vous parce
qu'ils apprécient valérie pécresse
moi j'aurais préféré que valérie
rassembler la majorité c'est le but pour
donner des logiques de partie et
malheureusement la proportionnelle
si on pouvait garder à venir
départementale se serait ce serait le
minimum mais c'est surtout que c'est la
loi des partis du choix des partis et
des jeux d'appareils partie est ce que
les joueurs olitique aujourd'hui non non
alors est ce qu'ils aiment ou balistique
est ce qu'ils aimaient la politique à 86
et ce qu'ils aimaient politique et puis
si cela semble représenter l'état
français était alors la proportionnelle
intégrale comme vous le savez mais je me
suis posé la question pourquoi vous êtes
revenu sur la proportionnelle vous étiez
d'accord au départ puis vous vous êtes
revenus en disant qu'on n'avait pas la
possibilité actuellement de mettre la
proportionnelle à l'ordre du jour
parlementaire
voilà
c'est toujours possible où s'ébat ce qui
vous arrive
mais vous pouvez mais vous pouvez le
faire à nos côtés parce qu'on se bat
pour le voir référendum soit parce que
la voie parlementaire sera rivière chez
qu'on peut pas obtenir le référendum
allez il est temps maintenant d'aller
faire un tour par le figaro live nous
attend vincent roux va sans bonsoir
qu'est ce que vous avez retenu dans le
film d'actualité vous suivez une
question a pas très bien que les
lecteurs du figaro c'est l'impact
psychologique et économique du
confinement
alors questions à patrick mignola qui
est un élu des alpes we're new here
était peut-être savoir bien entendu les
remontées mécaniques sont fermées est ce
que vous pensez que ça n'a pas trop que
ça n'a pas trop duré et que est ce que
vous pensez et finalement il faudrait
les rouvrir alors vous savez je vais
vous faire une confidence savait
difficile de de skier au mois de mai
juin en tout cas ça nous servira à rien
en revanche il faut absolument les
soutenir c'est donc donc l'ouverture
aujourd'hui ne serait plus utile et au
contraire vous feriez travailler des
gens pendant quinze jours trois semaines
ils perdraient plus d'argent que ce
qu'ils ont déjà perdu jusqu'à présent en
revanche on a pris les mesures de
soutien qui sont très importantes pour
que le l'économie direct de la montagne
ne s'apaise pas c'est ce sont des
mesures qui sont inimaginables à nulle
autre pareille
un plan d'investissement imaginez vous
dans un département comme la savoie
c'est trois cent mille euros d'argent
public par heure attendu au monde
économie de façon est-ce que malgré ses
ailes vous ne craignez pas que les
stations fasse faillite alors peut-être
pas en savoie mais dans d'autres
alain dans d'autres chaînes par facile
centrale dans les pyrénées alors vous
avez parfaitement raison mais toute la
montagne est concerné n'y a pas de
différence entre les massifs et donc
c'est pas forcément des stations qui
peuvent être en faillite
ce sont des entreprises il travaille en
amont ou en aval de se fiancer à thouars
rossignol et mme antier des belles
boîtes comme comme rossignol
me poma aujourd'hui sont en train de
regarder si elles vont pas être obligé
de faire des plans sociaux
donc il va falloir qu'on n'atteigne
vis-à-vis de cette deuxième vague
économie de vrais objectifs avec des
fonds participatif et que l'argent
public cette fois viennent pas seulement
en soutien mais viennent au capital mais
ça c'est la mauvaise année l'an prochain
merci vincent et je remercie aussi et
servane massa et robert et d'accessoires
du trou merci merci à vous patrick
mignola d'avoir subi votre audition
publique
une émission qui revient lundi à 19h30
merci bonne soirée
[Musique]